set up i want to introduce uh stefan
wagger he is a
assistant professor of operations
information and technology at
stanford university i'm in the graduate
school of business um and he's also an
assistant professor of statistics by
courtesy
i believe he's actually a stanford lifer
i think he did his undergrad here and
his
um phd in statistics and now his faculty
so you can correct me if i'm wrong but
it is it is a beautiful place
so his research lies in the intersection
of causal inference optimization and
statistical learning
and he's particularly interested in
developing new solutions to classical
problems
kind of at the intersection of decision
making economics and statistics
that also kind of leverage recent
developments in machine learning
i'll say that i've had the pleasure of
collaborating with him and one of his
students over the last couple years and
it's been
really exciting to get to sort of better
understand um some of the new insights
from econometrics
i'm still early in that learning process
but it's really exciting to hear about
those other techniques and that also
we've been collaborating and just to
illustrate the range of the work that
he's doing
on um some healthcare work now um and
looking at uh
different questions around comparing
supervised machine learning versus um
sort of
causal counterfactual models so i
thank you so much for coming and uh take
it away
thanks a lot emma for the uh invitation
for the introduction
it's a pleasure to be here um so today i
want to talk about something that
it's a it's a topic from causal
inference that i think
hasn't received much attention and
reinforcement learning so far
but it seems to me that there should be
a lot of connections between the two so
that's why
i wanted to talk about that today um and
the topic is uh
interference so what i mean by that
um the interference is that okay most
literature on evaluating a policy
including in reinforcement learning in
bandits
and causal imprints and so forth is
focused on a setting
where if you take an action on one unit
you affect that unit
if i give you surgery i may help you
survive i'm probably not going to help
your friend survive by giving you
surgery
right but in many applications the
assumption
just isn't right like if we're thinking
about
if your friend gets a covet vaccine like
that's totally going to help you not get
covet also
um so here if the action is vaccination
vaccination doesn't
just affect the person who's vaccinated
it'll affect others too um
on a different note in a housing setting
if your friend gets
a housing subsidy and they used to buy a
house
then that's gonna reduce the housing
supply in your area
and that'll make it it'll raise high
prices and it'll make it harder for you
to buy a house
so there's just this kind of large class
of application across different areas
where
an action taken on one person affects
others too
and if you don't account for this you're
just gonna
mess up when you're estimating the
effect evaluating the effect of a policy
overall so what i wanted to talk about
today is just
at a high level what are some good
models for capturing this kind of
interference
what kind of results can we prove in the
context of these models and how much
harder is interference to make policy
evaluation
so in this talk i actually won't be
doing any rl which may be kind of funny
given them
given the topic of this session but on
the other hand like
what's rl right you have
at least a single trajectory rl you have
a single trajectory and
in time you have a bunch of action
points
where you can do something and right the
whole problem in rl is kind of
i want to understand how an action taken
today affects me today but also affects
me tomorrow and the day after
by changing a state or something and
what's interference
you have a bunch of units they're not
spread on time they're spreading space
and now kind of taking an action on one
unit in space is going to affect other
people
elsewhere in space so in that sense kind
of
interference is just the transpose of
the rl problem of course there are a lot
of differences in rl you have this kind
of temporal structure you can write down
an mdp
we're very good at that kind of modeling
um spatial interference kind of other
types of interference
the modeling work isn't as well
developed but
there should still be a bunch of
connections
so okay
[Music]
we're talking about interference i just
wanted to kind of briefly say what is
the kind of
simplest thing you can do without
interference and that's the maintenance
analysis of the randomized trial
we want to see does giving you surgery
help you survive well what are we going
to do we're going to write down two
potential outcomes
why zero why one what would have
happened to you without surgery or with
surgery
uh and then the main result is that if
assignment of surgery was random then
you can take average survival for people
who got surgery versus average survival
for people who didn't
and that's a consistent estimate of the
average treatment effect that is the
average effective surgery
on survival this is very nice
highlights the central role of
randomization but
what's very important here is that this
notation kind of rules out
interference kind of automatically
when i write down y i zero what this
means is that
there's no way that kind of your friend
getting surgery could affect you
in any way in this invitation
um once we allow for interference the
world looks different
we don't just have two potential
outcomes it's not like you could have
been treated or not treated and that's
what determines your outcome
there's actually if there are n people
in your study there are two to the n
treatment combinations you could give to
those n people
and your outcome could in principle
depend on all 2 to the n
treatment assignments so now you have
exponentially many potential outcomes in
sample size
which is kind of a problem i i don't
think it's possible to solve this in
general right
if you have linearly increasing sample
size and you're exponentially increasing
complexity like what are you supposed to
do
so in order to do anything we need to
make assumptions we need to assume some
kind of structure on the interference
mechanism
so we can get rid of this exponential
blow-up and we also need to carefully
define our causal estimate
or kind of the policy we want to
evaluate in order to make progress
so today i want to talk about kind of
two very different ways
of doing this uh the
first i think this is kind of by far the
most prevalent in statistics literature
and this kind of generalizes the
classical work on randomized trials
nicely is
to kind of you can assume a graph and
you're going to use that graph to
collapse down the space of two to the n
potential outcomes you'd have to deal
with usually
so we're going to assume that we have
our n units we're going to put them on
vertices of a graph
and we're going to draw an edge between
any two units if
treatment given to one can also affect
the other
so this is called network interference
i'm also going to pair it with this
assumption of
anonymous interference which this
assumption people usually make
in this model also and this is that if
you're node number four
uh you have neighbors your nodes are
neighbors five two and three
uh you actually don't care about exactly
who got treated among these three
neighbors you only care about what
fraction
of your neighbors got treated so if you
have
10 people you interact with maybe you
don't care about exactly who gets
vaccinated you just care about
7 out of 10 getting vaccinated and
with this assumes then your potential
outcomes collapse right they just
now you depend on they depend on uh your
treatment assignment and the average
treatment assignment for your neighbors
this is kind of a special case of what
arno and sammy call an exposure mapping
and kind of now now we're in business um
we still need to define a causal
estimate
uh but here there are many reasonable
things you can do
um one natural way to decompose this is
that you can define
if we're thinking about vaccination you
can think about the total effect
so this would assume like how much would
the kind of average number of cases of a
disease go down if you go up from
vaccinating 60 to 70 percent of the
population
um then you can talk about the direct
effect given the current
situation what is the protective effect
for you getting vaccinated yourself on
your own
avoidance of the disease and then
there's the indirect effect
which is kind of every way you benefit
from the vaccine that's not captured by
the direct effect
and the some of the direct and indirect
effects is the total effect
and this connects nicely to kind of what
we usually do because the direct effect
in in the case of a randomized trial
with no interference the direct effect
is just the average treatment effect
where the indirect effect is zero
and like the presence of interference
means that the indirect effect becomes
non-zero and like i said this is kind of
a pretty popular model for doing
interference in both statistics and
econometrics
so there's a bunch of work on this
uh in the case of the direct effect i
mentioned kind of the direct effect is
the thing that in a randomized trial
just becomes the average treatment
effect we're used to estimating
and there's here i just put in some of
the most recent references but these are
references to older stuff also
uh sevia arnold hodgson's show that
it's essentially if you pretend that you
have data from a randomized trial
uh but you actually have interference
then you're going to end up estimating
the direct effect
and you they give some balance on how
fast you estimate the direct effect
this d depends on the degree of the
graph so they show that you're generally
going to be consistent if you're not too
dense but
the denser the graph the worse your
bounds get
and for the indirect effect it's harder
as you might expect
but there are still some results in kind
of specific
models okay i kind of because i pitched
this as a
as a general kind of overview talk but i
also of course do want to talk about
some kind of recent things i've been
thinking about in this space
that that i'm excited about maybe kind
of connect to some
uh mathematical ideas others in this
community have been looking at
so so one thing i've been thinking about
recently
here these bounds um they're all
in the setting where kind of first you
place your node your units
on the vertices of a graph then you draw
some edges between them
and then you try to do analysis that
would be valid for any graph
and i guess we know like there can be
some weird graphs and difficult graphs
to deal with
so what we wanted to ask is like can you
do better if you kind of focus on some
typical graphs as opposed to just kind
of arbitrarily bad graphs
and you kind of there's a lot of
literature on kind of probabilistic
random graphs and can we use results
from this literature to
make progress so
as kind of a first step in this
direction um we looked at one specific
generative model for graphs uh this is
the graphon
so just very quickly we essentially
assume that any two nodes
have a type and given two types of nodes
there's some affinity
and based on this affinity you flip a
coin if it comes up heads
then you draw an edge between the two
nodes otherwise so this is kind of a
widely studied model for random graphs
and we consider this in a dense and a
sparse
setting and we just wanted to see how
well can you estimate direct and
indirect effects
um in this kind of setting
um so
our first result and i thought this was
quite encouraging
is i'll just go back quickly remember
for the direct effect
we have general results showing that
kind of
familiar estimators with average
treatment effect in randomized trials
are consistent for the direct effect
but this paper it doesn't give a
distribution of this estimator
and it gives some bounds for the error
but these bounds
generally get worse in dense graphs
on the other hand what we show is that
if we're willing to make these graphon
generative assumptions
um then not only do we get consistency
but we get an exact distributional
result we get a central limit theorem
and actually your rate of conversion
doesn't depend on how dense the graph is
whether you're dense or sparse you
always get root and rates of convergence
for the direct effect
um and that kind of variance inflation
you get due to interference is this term
i it depends on the graph on in this
kind of
way that you can write down um so this
was kind of a first encouraging results
showing that kind of
interesting stuff does happen under
interference and and kind of depending
on how you model you might get kind of
much more optimistic looking results uh
than you'd think otherwise
um could you give us this brief
intuition for why it shouldn't
explicitly depend on the
degree of yeah so so i i know like your
first intuition would be right like
the more neighbors you have like surely
the more noise there should be but
now one thing that's doing a lot of work
is here
we don't care about if we're looking at
vaccination
we don't care about exactly the
identities of your neighbors who are
vaccinated
we just care about what fraction of
people you talk to are vaccinated
and what ends up happening here is kind
of the more neighbors you have
the less kind of any given neighbor
can affect you the fraction of a
vaccinated neighbor so this is kind of
the intuition for why kind of this this
washes out
um on a technical level then you do
it's a handsome right type concentration
argument that shows that the
interactions between who gets kind of
two different
neighbors being treated uh goes away and
this q
i if you stare at it uh you can see that
this is
this isn't going to like push forward
thing it's like it measures
if i get treated how much does this on
average
push other people's responses up
so for every person you contribute to
the variance by like a direct thing and
an indirect thing
and then you get a central limit there
um
yeah so this is
this is one result we also looked at the
indirect effect
um this was actually interesting you
could
you could imagine doing then direct
effect so so remember
the indirect effect asks um kind of if
we go from vaccinating 60 to 61
of people how does um how does the kind
of
prevalence of disease change in a way
that kind of goes beyond the direct
effect
and what you could imagine doing is you
could kind of do a horvitz thompson
type estimator where you kind of look at
kind of you have people who have a
bigger or smaller fraction of
treated neighbors and try to use that
kind of weighting
based on how many of your neighbors are
treated
um to kind of try to extrapolate to
different
treatment fractions and this implies a
very
kind of nice looking estimator of the
indirect effect
is this form it's kind of a correlation
between your outcome and your
fraction of treated neighbors and this
looks nice
and i think when we first saw this i was
like this is this is going to be good
but it actually turns out this is not a
good estimator in
any kind of reasonable setting this
estimator is going to diverge
its variance blows up and
so this was this was weird and here i'm
going to go too fast
for you to the paper if you're
interested turns out kind of when you
look at this in detail
the variance blows up but
all the problematic variance is kind of
in direction that's aligned with
principal components of the graph on
so essentially and it turns out you can
get rid of this by doing the following i
take the edge matrix
run pca on the edge matrix look at the
principal components
take project out all the noise that's in
the direction of these pcs and then run
this estimator
after projecting out that noise and and
that thing works
um and it's going to satisfy central
limit theorem again
uh but here your rate of convergence is
going to depend on the sparsity um
the sparser the graph the better you're
going to okay
so this is something you can do here
also
but okay so this was one model network
interference it kind of
lets you very directly add potential
outcome
like add interference into the potential
outcome model you can put structure
on this interference thing and then you
can prove some results in general you
can prove stronger results under random
graph assumptions
i think this is kind of it's
statistically a very nice model i expect
there to be
much more to say about it um but
so this is one way to capture
interference effects um
i promise though that i wouldn't just
give one model i'd give kind of
talk about different ways of
incorporating interference and
talk mentioned to housing subsidies
earlier um
another version of this that gets a lot
of attention in
economics is in understanding the effect
of agricultural subsidies
um if i subsidize one for a farmer
uh they're probably going to produce a
lot more
corn if i subsidize all the corn
farmers uh they're gonna produce really
a lot more corn
uh this is but demand is what it is so
this is gonna
reduce the price of corn and this is
gonna yield smaller effects
kind of if you want to understand the
effect of subsidies you need to
you know be able to capture this kind of
interference effects this is kind of a
very generic phenomenon in any kind of
economic application
and what happens here is there's clearly
interference right
subsidies actions taken on some people
are also going to affect
outcomes for others but
maybe here network interference doesn't
feel like such a natural tool anymore
i'm right because essentially there's no
network structure
i don't care which farmer is producing
more corn i just care that more corn is
being
produced and that this depresses prices
and i can make less money by producing
corn
so there's no network structure but
interference is mediated by something
else that we also understand well right
interference is mediated by prices
that come from kind of matching supply
with demand
and what can you say here
so now do this differently instead of
kind of trying to build uh
more general theoretical results i'll
just talk about something
we did in a very concrete application uh
i'm kind of motivated by very concrete
application this is
uh suppose you have a platform that's
um trying to kind of connect freelance
labor
uh with a demand for labor and they're
trying to
optimize incentives for workers to join
the platform
um if you want to think about this in
terms of a familiar application you
could think of like
lyft figuring out how much to pay
drivers
to drive the left that kind of applies
to any freelance
work platform and so here we're going to
assume a model where every time period
the platform can learn over time and in
every time period
the platform first kind of chooses how
much to pay people
how
uh then kind of given this payment
potential workers think
um how much are they going to get paid
they're also going to look at kind of if
they do choose to work
what's the chance say if they're driving
to the left that they're actually going
to get to drive or that they're just
going to sit their idle
with no one asking for a ride and then
they kind of look at their expected
revenue
uh they compare that to an outside
option and then they choose to join
platform and we're going to assume that
the system is in equilibrium
so this is just kind of a very concrete
model that kind of gives rise to
these equilibrium effects i was talking
about earlier if you
pay some people more you make them more
likely to work
oh that means that they're going to soak
up more demand so that leaves less
demand for others
and when you're trying to choose an
optimal policy you need to account for
those effects
so yeah any any approach to learning
should account for cannibalization
effects
um how can you do this
there are essentially uh two two
approaches
uh that i'm aware of a one is
you could just kind of every day try
different policies
and and deploy them globally uh
you could today you could try to kind of
pay everyone fifteen dollars per unit of
work
and tomorrow you try paying everyone
twenty dollars per unit of work
and there's no interference because
you're always intervening on everyone
so that's fine or there's kind of no
bias for missing interference because
you're always
intervening on everyone so that's good
the downside is you essentially have a
very small sample size because every
time you take an action you have 200
interfere on everyone
and if they're kind of any kind of
idiosyncrasies by day
like there's a supply increase or
decrease that day that noise hits you
very hard
i should mention this is a special case
of derivative free stochastic
optimization which is
something that's studied a lot in the in
the
you know banded literature or then the
question is can we do something better
by actually
thinking about where this interference
is coming from it's coming from kind of
price equilibrium effects
and then can we use equilibrium modeling
to kind of fix gradient descent and do
something more
uh familiar gradient optimization type
stuff here and okay i'm not gonna have
the time today to go into detail about
what to do exactly
but just kind of a very high level
intuition is what we're going to imagine
doing is
if currently we were thinking of paying
everyone 15
per unit of work then we're actually
randomly gonna offer to pay some people
fifteen dollars and ten cents and others
fourteen dollars and ninety cents
we're going to kind of put small mean
zero percentations
and then you can regress people's choice
of participating in the marketplace
against these small mean zero
perturbations
and this is going to give you an
estimate of a marginal response function
that is in equilibrium how sensitive are
people to
being paid a little bit more this
marginal response function of course
is not what we care about because it
ignores cannibalization effects
but kind of the main result of the paper
is that we understand where
cannibalization comes from it comes from
price
equilibrium effects and then once you
have this marginal response effect
then you can actually do totally
reasonable things that one could hope to
do in practice
and turn delta hat into an estimate of
the policy relevant gradient
and the reason this is possible is
essentially there are two things going
on in the marketplace there's one that's
kind of very mechanistic supply demand
respond to each other in some way and
that we understand
and then there's this very kind of
inscrutable part of the problem
where different people have different
outside options
and different people will choose to kind
of work for you under different
conditions and
there are so many different types of
people you could never hope to learn
that
but it turns out that this delta hat
this marginal response function already
captures
all the strange ways in which people are
different in the way we need it
so kind of mapping from this to a policy
relevant gradient only involves kind of
calculations one could do given
reasonable information
so um anyways
uh like i said if i unfortunately don't
have the time to go into more detail
about how this works exactly
and then i wanted did want to say that
this makes a huge difference in practice
if you can kind of capture these
equivalent effects and
do kind of gradient based learning as
opposed to kind of zero
order gradient free learning that kind
of just gives everyone the same
intervention
you can be much more accurate so here's
results from one simulation example
you could worry about kind of your
learning how much regret did you
incur during the learning phase you
could then kind of think about deploying
a decision in the future
how well are you doing there here's the
method
we're looking at that kind of uses
equilibrium effects
uh to kind of equilibrium model into
correct guarantee and descent
we converge very very fast
you can have negligible regret whereas
here kind of different variants of
zeroth order optimization
this family we didn't know how to tune
it so we just did all the things
uh so you can get different tradeoffs
between how you do in sample versus in
the future
but there's just an order of magnitude
difference in how accurate you are
and if you don't believe that we
implemented the simulation
fairly then we also have a theorem which
is in large systems
uh this is kind of with a bunch of by
large systems i mean we're kind of a
bunch of workers so you don't have these
kind of small sample combinatorial
effects of who which is to work or not
um we show that kind of under reasonable
assumptions we get logity regret as we
learn over time we can learn quickly
whereas global experimentation can't do
better than
t regret so there's a big separation and
again
at least the proof for the lower bound
is essentially follows directly from
from this work on derivative free
stochastic optimization
it's just not possible to get good rates
so anyways i think according to my time
keeping i have
two minutes left so i just wanted to
kind of
close by saying that um most work on
policy evaluation
kind of assumes that if you intervene on
one unit
uh only that unit uh responds
uh but in many applications interference
actually
plays a central role and if you don't
account for interference you're going to
get the wrong answer
as to the effects of a policy there
there are many ways
of adding interference into a model um
here i just wanted to talk about two
different ways of doing this
network interference kind of generalizes
the potential outcomes model
and let's just add interference in a
kind of familiar setting
um on the other hand this kind of
equilibrium modeling this kind of seems
closer to game theory uh we
we understand that kind of there's a
shared resource different people are
going to be competing for this shared
resource and reacting to each other's
decisions
based on their own utility functions but
again
but again then you can reuse results
from game theory to understand these
equilibrium effects
and this can be kind of help you capture
interference effects in different
applications and yeah
i mean like i said earlier maybe this is
just me being dogmatic but
kind of in in enough generality you
could think of
single trajectory rl as having a bunch
of units that are connected by a
temporal
um temporal kind of
ordered and time and then an mdp would
be just another way of kind of
connecting how actions taken on one unit
so anyways there's a bunch of way of
doing this
and i think there is a lot of work to be
done into kind of building interference
into our policy evaluation toolkit
um that's both a lot of exciting
physical questions and and i think a lot
of uh
impact and being able to uh solve
important problems better
but anyways that's all i had for today
and here i kind of reference the two
papers i talked about and these have
references kind of much more broadly uh
to this letter
thank you
thanks for the great talk um uh we have
time for like maybe one or two questions
before the next person
yeah can i ask a quick question um
excellent talk stefan i think this is an
excellent
problem to study um so i'm wondering
what what is the connection to
say multi-agent reinforcement learning
with like say
agents as large as and so it looks like
you are incorporating some
specific assumptions on how how these um
like
a large number of patients are
interacting with each other
yes um exactly uh
i i i actually
in asking this question you probably
have some specific references in mind
that i'm not familiar with so
i if you if you have something like that
to share i'd be very happy to take a
look
uh most of kind of uh when i was
thinking about this i've been thinking
about kind of
from the perspective the causal
inference and economics literatures
on this kind of stuff um i was just
referring to the talk yesterday by
dimitri sorry unfortunately i
i wish we could have all been a person
because then it's much more easier
to just sit there but now it's still
like the usual meetings are still there
so i haven't been able to watch that
video yet unfortunately
yeah another thing is that i think it it
might make sense to think about in the
network setting to think about say
stochastic block models or
mixed membership stochastic block models
and so on so so you can like
work on the groups and different groups
of agents so you don't have to to deal
with a really a huge number of agents
so that could be a promising direction
so so in the
in the network setting right there the
graph one model we're looking at
that's generally oh i see you guys think
block mode so
and and in the paper many of the
examples we have for the stochastic
block model because that's
very easy
i guess we need to move on to the next
speaker um is me hilo there
um hey sean hey stefan so if you could
stop sharing your screen and let me
harlow um
i'll go in yeah thank you um
[Music]
oh man yeah it is painful to be so far
away from you guys so
it's a pleasure to introduce me harlow
ivanovic
one of many amazing stories that come
out of uc santa barbara
the hollow